[Música]
vamos a comenzar con la plática que
tengo para todos ustedes el día de hoy y
pues les quiero platicar sobre algo que
es lo que nos transmite la música muchas
veces me he dado cuenta y conforme va
pasando el tiempo y pues vayamos cada
vez nos envolvemos en un mundo más
mediático en el cual a través de redes
sociales nos dicen que pensar nos meten
ideas distintas no siempre nos siembran
odio nos dicen que escuchar más sin
embargo no sabemos qué es lo que nos
están queriendo transmitir a través de
esa música que nos pone en verdad y pues
bueno vamos a comenzar con un poco de
teórico verdad y pues vaya a la música
qué es lo que transmite la música
transmite emociones la música transmite
sentimientos
remontando la época de la música clásica
los compositores de todos los temas que
escuchamos en su música a ellos imprimen
sus sentimientos sus emociones y claro
cuando la música instrumental era la que
predominaba que no era vocal y no había
letras en las cuales podíamos escuchar
los mensajes pues los compositores nos
querían decir algo también verdad
desgraciadamente ahora como digo vivimos
en una época tan mediática y nos creemos
lo que nos dicen pero no nos damos a las
tareas de investigar verdad de ver que
hay en el trasfondo de todo eso y a
veces me decían personas y es que la
música clásica es muy aburrida el vídeo
pero realmente conoces de qué están
hablando y me dicen pues no simplemente
se me hace aburrida le digo bueno pues
conoces algo de historia conoces algo
acerca del compositor no pues tampoco
sabemos quién es le digo pues bueno vaya
pues el compositor puede ser fulano de
tal vivienda la época y fíjate que lo
que pasaba en el mundo en esa época era
lo que le daba a él
a componer su música lo que él sentía
por sus antecedentes familiares
socioeconómicos etcétera también le
daban mucho material para trabajar sus
obras que él componía verdad y le decía
yo leo tu sabes que durante la época de
la revolución francesa etcétera pues
muchos de los temas que se componían
eran temas en los cuales se elevaba el
patriotismo en los cuales los
compositores tanto de música como de
poesía y otras artes sus temas
principales eran derrocar a la monarquía
darle poder al pueblo
ibai a derrocar a los tiranos que los
tenían muriendo de hambre en muchas
situaciones en distintos países verdad
entonces vaya la música tiene mucho que
ver con la historia al igual que todo el
arte las corrientes artísticas entre
ellas musicales pues van cambiando
acordes las situaciones que están
sucediendo en el mundo
y desgraciadamente simplemente
escuchamos
no se nos queda nada no sabemos qué es
lo que nos están queriendo transmitir a
través de su música y desafortunadamente
también es triste decirlo pero incluso
en músicos ellos nada más los tocan y
tampoco saben qué es lo que nos están
queriendo decir o lo que nos están
queriendo transmitir cuando a través de
la música cuando interpretas algún tema
pues le tienes que poner un pedacito del
corazón porque tú tienes que transmitir
a través de tu interpretación lo que a
lo mejor ese compositor nos quiso decir
en dicha obra escuchaba yo a compañeros
que tocan música de rock y que te llaman
el rock clásico verdad les decía yo
positivo está todo dar luego a mí me
encanta el rock clásico 70 60 80 leo
pero realmente tú sabes que lo que nos
quiere decir a lo mejor la música del
rock de los setentas me decía no pero
pues está toda la música que tocan
creedence y que tocan
2 etc y si sabías que una gran mayoría
de esos sobre todo en los grupos
norteamericanos la música es una música
que habla de protestas que hablan sobre
la guerra de vietnam que ellos querían
evitar sobre cómo
ellos este pues vaya estaban en contra
de que la juventud norteamericana fuera
a participar a una guerra que para ello
no tenía ninguna causa y como la
juventud que no tenía dinero para
estudiar o para adquirir un trabajo pues
la única salida era ingresar al ejército
y a tu suerte verdad a un país
desconocido en la cual prácticamente era
una muerte segura más sin embargo
también existían los jóvenes adinerados
que ellos le podían sacar la vuelta a
ese sistema selectivo porque pues eran
hijos de personas con dinero y pues se
podían ahorrar
la desgracia de ir a la guerra verdad y
les decía yo por las estás cantando las
estás tocando entonces o sea todo sale
de la boca para afuera y no hay ninguna
forma de pensar que te dé a entender lo
que están queriendo decir y me decían
'vaya nunca me había puesto a pensar en
eso y nunca había escuchado las letras
de las canciones
y digo yo vaya pues en qué mundo estamos
viviendo en lo cual estamos actuando de
alguna manera
pero sin pensar que realmente lo que
estamos causando o qué es lo que nos
causa actuar de esa forma
regresando un poco más atrás existen
muchos temas de música clásica sobre
todos los que le llaman los poemas
sinfónicos y como decían es música
aburrida de le digo no es aburrida y les
digo vaya hay temas tan bonitos solo que
no conocemos las historias les platicaba
yo sobre la música de spears y
compositor italiano y les digo vaya en
sus temas que él compone de roma
él le quiere dar a la población el
sentimiento a remontarse la época del
imperio romano
y tú lees la historia sobre las
composiciones de él y dicen no manches
es cierto o sea eso que se esté
escuchando son las fanfarrias donde
están recibiendo a su ejército que viene
entrando triunfal a la ciudad de roma
por la vía apia
y su ejército viene triunfal después de
conquistar tierras nórdicas y más
terrenos para el imperio oye y si miras
escuchaste como vienen marchando los
soldados los elefantes que traen en la
en el ejército y le empiezan a encontrar
un sentido a estas composiciones
desgraciadamente no nos damos a la tarea
de investigar qué es lo que nos quieren
decir cuáles son los mensajes que nos
quieren transmitir a través de esa
música
la música tiene un gran poder que a
veces no nos damos cuenta y lo pasamos
desapercibidos la música tiene el poder
de cambiar nuestro estado de ánimo de
darnos o de establecer un estado de
ánimo según lo que estamos escuchando tú
vas a una fiesta y pues obviamente la
música tiene que ser de alegría tiene
que motivarnos a que nos envolvemos a la
fiesta verdad vaya no va a ser el
carnaval de brasil y escuchar música
triste de hecho para no cosas por el
estilo verdad es una fiesta es una
celebración y pues vaya la música de la
samba pues vaya nos ponen ese en ese
medio verdad en el cual se nos alegra el
corazón queremos participar en la fiesta
y estamos entrando a un estado de ánimo
en el cual la música no lo está dando
verdad uno de los grandes ejemplos que
yo pongo sobre como la música nos cambia
el estado de ánimo es la música que se
utiliza en el cine y vaya y pienso yo
que la música sin música el cine no
sería lo mismo
pues vaya tú puedes ver una película con
alguna escena de muerte
y vaya pues si tú estás viendo lo que
está aconteciendo pero qué es lo que
realmente te hace entrar en ese estado
de ánimo donde a lo mejor hasta lloras
pues es la música verdad la música que
está en el transfondo y que pasa
desapercibida porque nosotros estamos
viendo a los actores
interpretar la escena y la música
no sabemos por la música nos está
poniendo en el estado de ánimo que está
el el actor o la actriz en la escena en
el que están tristes por una perdida en
el cual se están enamorando o están
llevando a la muchacha que quieren al
lugar para declararse le por fin o vaya
a una película de terror verdad
tú puedes ver la película y si pues vaya
viene el monstruo el atacante a realizar
su fechoría pero vaya sin la música pues
no se siente igual verdad porque tú lo
estás viendo y estás con que hay ahí
está atrás de la puerta pero la música
es la que nos está poniendo los buenos
responde verdad menor los pelos de punta
en la piel de gallina en la cual estás
alcohol es te estás metiendo en un en
una escena
pánico de miedo y de terror más sin
embargo pasa desapercibido y que otra
cosa pasa que pues cuando llegan los
créditos de la película al último hasta
mero abajo es el compositor en la
película fulano de tal etcétera y digo
vaya que el gran trabajo de los
compositores del cine de podernos llevar
a ese lugar
o como la música que se pone en las
películas de vaqueros que esto las
escuchas y aunque ya no estés viendo en
la película dices ahí estoy en él estoy
en el campo caballos etcétera el mundo
fulano de tal que salía antes en unos
comerciales pero escuchaba la música y
automáticamente te remonta a esos
lugares
te hace que la música nos hace viajar y
nos hace y nos trae recuerdos recuerdos
a veces que son desde la infancia y que
después los volvemos a escuchar y nos
acordamos de buenos momentos que tenemos
uno desde otro de los grandes ejemplos
que yo les doy sobre los estados de
ánimo es la música de la película
tiburón la cual me ha tocado dirigir y
le decía yo a los compañeros cuando
estábamos ensayando les decían es que
les digo imagínate que tú estás en el
agua y el primer estar
el tiburón todavía no llega hasta allá
lejos pero tú ya lo viste sí ya como qué
tal
es tu latido del corazón donde hay
canijo ahí viene
y conforme el tema se va adelantando
imagínense qué es tan tan tan tan tan
iba creciendo en dinámica y en velocidad
y vaya es el latido del corazón donde
empieza a palpitar te empiezas a
preocupar empieza a entrar en pánico
porque el tiburón te va a comer
y la música en la que nos está dando ese
esas emociones acerca de la situación
que está sucediendo imagínense en la
misma escena se han visto esta película
pero no sean la mejor con la peli con
otro tipo de música imagínense la con
con una cumbia o algo y pues vaya no
sería el mismo sentido que nos estuviera
transmitiendo
por el lo que quieren ellos alimentarnos
a nosotros verdad entonces vaya a la
música tiene gran poder sobre las
emociones de los seres humanos y
volvemos a lo mismo estamos tan
distraídos que todo esto pasa
desapercibido no nos damos cuenta la
música también tiene el gran poder de
transmitir cosas malas cosas que no son
buenas y que a mi punto de ver han
estado destruyendo a la sociedad poco a
poco y de una manera inconsciente porque
porque son cosas comerciales y es lo que
más se vende y tú vas en tu carro y por
realización de radio y está una canción
y al principio no te gusta y le cambias
de estación y está la misma y le cambias
a otra y está en la misma
y de rato ya blandos cantando y ya te la
sabes y les dices ajá te saben la
canción fulana de tal nombre está bien
gacha pero si la estás cantando y te la
sabes pues ya te la metieron en la
cabeza ya la traes tan grabada y no
saben ni siquiera qué es lo que dice
porque está distraído con tus problemas
y con otras cosas
que ya te metieron algo y vas en el
coche y vas con tus hijos
y tus hijos también las van cantando y a
lo mejor esa canción habla de sexo en
una manera
vulgar y a lo mejor tú eres mujer y tú
dyson y tienes hijas y la van cantando y
esa canción habla de como degradan a la
mujer en una manera sexual o de cómo la
toman como un objeto pero tú vas bien
feliz cant y cante no y tus hijos
también y ay qué bonito se ve mi niña
cantando la canción que dice que me van
a llevar a un motel etcétera verdad
entonces debemos de ser un poco más
selectivos con la música que escuchamos
y con lo que le damos sobre todo a
nuestra gente a escuchar verdad
vas a las escuelas a las kermeses y por
desgracia es la música repudiante que
ponen que no nos dejan no nos transmiten
nada bueno
y se los estamos dando si nos estamos
alimentando y con eso estamos se está
colaborando a que una forma de pensar y
que una sociedad poco a poco vaya
decayendo más si nos dejemos de
preocupar por las cosas que realmente
importan y nos volvamos más
superficiales y materialistas otro de
los temas que a mí tampoco me agrada y
que desgraciadamente con la música cada
vez se vuelve más
más importante o cada vez lo meten más
por los medios de comunicación
son los temas que hablan sobre drogas y
violencia
y vaya las ponen y las ponen y van a las
vas a las fiestas y es lo que escuchas
hasta que llega un momento en que la
sociedad sobre todo la juventud que es
un momento en el cual están confundidos
y todavía no saben qué es lo que van a
hacer de ellos o que en cualquier
momento sus caminos se pueden desviar
pero los temas estos hacen ver que esas
actividades etcétera se vuelvan normales
y sean aceptables esos famosos temas que
se manejan ahora de que éramos pobres no
teníamos nada pero ahora somos ricos y
tenemos todo y tengo mujeres y tengo y
voy a las fiestas y tengo el mejor vino
y camionetas etcétera pero no te dicen
cómo lo hicieron
no dicen cuántas personas perdieron la
vida para que ellos lograran eso ni de
las frustraciones que ellos viven porque
quieren que se les reconozca lo que
ahora son y lo hacen de esta forma y la
combi que es lo que piensan la juventud
ellos comienzan a pensar pues yo también
quiero eso para que estudio para que
trabajo si mejor no puedo dedicar algún
ilícito el cual me va a dar todo en la
vida y erróneamente saben no saben
el costo y el precio de estas cosas
entonces yo a conclusión de mi plática
es vaya debemos de ser un poco más
inteligentes en que escuchamos y que le
damos a nuestras familias ser un poco
más estudioso sobre la música y pues
vaya a buscar cosas que se transmiten
decía el gran facundo cabral vivimos una
época en la que estamos distraídos de
las cosas
tan hermosas que la vida nos brinda
como los amaneceres como las flores que
nos regalan la primavera todos los años
como los moneros de manzanero los
nocturnos de chopin etcétera y estamos
enclaustrados en lo que los medios de
comunicación nos quieren alimentar mil
gracias y que dios los bendiga espero
que les haya gustado mi presentación
[Aplausos]